David is in Florida welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show David hey Dave how you doing
better than I deserve man how can I help
Hey so I wanted to call and ask you
about your advice when it comes to
approaching our student loan payments
right now for my wife and I and we're
doing we're doing baby step number two
which is snowballing our debt and it's
it's working well the with the months
that were able to do it but there's some
funds for some expenses will come up to
the point where our minimum payments for
student loans can there be a little
back-breaking and I know it's never a
good idea to go into more debt to help
pay them off or anything I wanted to ask
your advice on how to best go about
these loans to where we aren't losing
out every month on our minimum payment
and not being able to snowball the rest
what's your minimum payment it's about
$400 what's your household income
combined is about seventy thousand okay
and your total student loan debt
balances all together is what ah a
little over thirty thousand okay and
your interest rate is what on those
loans average of four point six percent
okay the only thing you would gain by
refinancing it be recasting the loans
and making you stay in debt longer right
and and you probably would go up and
interest rate to do that because you
have a fabulous interest rate yeah yeah
it's pretty good the only reason I the
only reason I tell people to refinance
is to get a lower interest rate or to
get to a fixed rate if they have a
variable and that's only on student
loans and so it sounds like more than
anything else we've just got some budget
items how much do you owe in your cars
we have one car and it's paid off okay
and how much is your house payment are
you're around 1250 a month and that's
really good for the area we're in that
was the cheapest we could find and a
whatever you are you in we're in Fort
Lauderdale Florida okay and how much is
coming
out of your check for 401k at the moment
none and how much of a tax refund did
you get last year um what we were
unemployed part of the year so it was re
I think it was about 2200 because it was
a 1250 rent and no car payment and only
a $400 student loan making seventy
thousand you shouldn't be that tight we
have a couple other credit cards that
were paying as well what's the balances
on those combined for about um six point
five thousand maybe a little less and
that's across that's across about five
or six different cards okay but somebody
make is $70,000 a years typically paying
off thirty six thousand five hundred
dollars in debt in two years mm-hmm
that's not barely making a four hundred
dollar payment mm-hmm that's like
fifteen hundred bucks a month going on
these stats so I don't know where your
money's going are you doing you're doing
the written budget I assume yes we are
mm-hmm I can't tell where your money's
going because there should be money left
in this equation it's not going to go
wrong okay you've not got too much
coming out for taxes you you've not got
a bunch of other payments you've only
got thirty six thousand five hundred
dollars in debt and student loans and
credit cards any of a fairly reasonable
house payment it's not gray or house
rent it's not great on your income but
it's not horrible it's not killing you
and so when I dig your budget I don't
know where all your money's going yeah
to be honest I feel like it does go to
random expenses that pop up like last
month we accidentally uh rear-ended a
our neighbor's car while backing up and
that set us back a bit and um you you
know stuff like that having to fix and
things around the apartment well that's
not really our our ability and Lords but
different things like medical bills and
stuff like that that are coming up is it
can be a little hard when also paying
the student
bill especially with insurance
insurances that were telling you though
is is the people living a normal life
doing their debt-free screams on this
show and that we do coaching with with a
thousand or 1200 allah grant making
seventy thousand dollars a year are
paying off the amount of debt that you
have in two years and there's thirty six
thousand divided by two is eighteen
hundred and that's fifteen hundred
dollars a month and you're struggling
with a four hundred dollar payment so
that tells me we have a thousand dollar
swing in your budget that I can't find
that's what I'm telling you other people
are doing what you're doing so much
better than you're doing it and that's
what I was trying to help you with I
can't I don't know where it's going I
think you need to get on the every
dollar budget and you and your wife need
to stay out of restaurants and you don't
need to be talking about a vacation and
there's no luxuries in this budget it's
scorched earth and no refinancing
student loans is not your problem you do
not need that you're gonna go up and
interest rate and stay in debt longer
and you will have addressed the symptom
not the problem the problem is we can't
find a thousand dollars in your budget
right now that's lost and I want you to
get in there and find it the scorched
earth your budget
meaning no life you have no life that
you clean this mess up that's what I
mean but scorched earth